hello everyone this is emily here from
audio science review
today i have a quick review for you uh
on this uh helm audio um
bolt deck uh these are little dongles
with usbc at one end
and 3.5 millimeter headphone jack
with so many phones these days not
having any headphone
output you're going to need one of these
even if they have a headphone output
many of them have very low amount of
power and can't drive any audiophile
headphones so these things can be quite
useful in getting almost desktop
class performance out of them now
some are really cheap you can get the
apple and google's
for nine bucks the apple one is actually
quite good
but a lot of the other ones aren't and
so it's important to look at
measurements
um and pricing goes everywhere
this one is hundred dollars almost so
it's expensive
as dongles go although you can go higher
than this uh
you can see on amazon it's 99 dollars
plus uh
prime free delivery a couple things are
unusual about this one is that it has
mqa decoding
i know some of you hate mqa but
it's getting some adoption because some
streaming services in us and especially
some in
china support it so more and more these
companies are
putting mqa decoding in here and then
the thing that's really unusual which i
hadn't seen uh
here oh sorry i didn't know that you
couldn't see the browser
um is this thx certification
uh i didn't know ts thx had come up with
any kind of certification
um it seems to be some kind of design
hygiene
it doesn't say exactly what but it
provides isolation from usb which is
good usb bus can be
pretty noisy and then rate dependent on
which device you plug it into
um it talks about different clocks and
what have you so
a little vague but that's what we test
we test to see if these claims are true
by the way for testing i hook these up
to windows pc
just plug this into my computer and
these are fully plug and play with
windows
and makes my testing easier because my
software
analyzer runs on windows um so
you you know when you buy one of these
know that you can use it both on your
phone and your
your computer so you're not just limited
to that
um there are no controls on this some of
them have volume controls and
and what have you this one has none
which is a little less convenient
rather have some physical volume
controls on it but otherwise it's pretty
robust little
chunky thing which i like
um i test this usually as a deck
meaning that i uh don't try to load the
output down
and treat them as if they were normal
desktop dac and
see what output they have a lot of them
only output one volt
which is uh way too low uh for driving
impedance headphones this one outputs
two volts which is quite nice
more would be better but it's very rare
to get more than two volts out of these
things
distortion here is almost minus 100 db
so below 96 db of cd
format which is good and that
basically dominates the sign at rating
cyanide is some of noise and distortion
but when one of them is a lot harder
than the other
that's the thing that determines it so
uh
if we look at the ranking if you plug
that into every deck that i've tested
some 350 400 dax
it lands in a green zone which i call
very competent um blue is just
fantastic but these dongles don't ever
get blue most of these dongles are
either in orange or many of them in red
so to get into green is is quite nice
the second test i run on these things is
a jitter test you
i don't know if you saw it in thx i
think there was some mention of
oscillators and
quality of that many times when i run
this jitter test which is this
sort of 12 kilohertz tone in here with
these dongles
uh there's pretty high level of noise
and
high level of unwanted spikes many of
them are probably from
the usb uh bus that's not very well
filtered
in these little tiny devices not a lot
of room in there
this one's actually very good the noise
floor is way down here
which is for dongle pretty good at -150
desktop products go down to minus 160.
it does have this uh train of pulses in
here whenever these pulses are
symmetrical
uh on both sides of our 12 kilos tone we
know that they're jitter
there's other ones like i don't know if
these are symmetrical or not but there
are random ones you get that are not
symmetrical those are just spurious
noise that's just getting injected this
test doesn't just measure jitter
it measures anything that comes out of
the dac but in this
case we actually have a clear case of
jitter it it seems to be at
one kilohertz intervals that's that's
the
frame size of usb so that may be what's
causing it but the nice thing is that
the level's at -130 db
so definitely not audible and uh
you know well below audibility so it's
nice for dongle again for this class is
quite nice
so uh the most important thing in these
things is power
number one problem with these when they
they get distorted is because they just
don't have enough output tiny little
device can't have you know huge power
electronics in them and uh so it's very
important to measure power so as before
i've shown you with headphone amps we
start with a high impedance load
load like 300 ohm and here we only get
13 milliwatts
um my threshold here is 100 milliwatt
but for desktop products i'll show you
in a second how it ranks
but uh we go down here plug that into
every dongle of this type some of these
dongles are actually quite large so
these ones way up here are not tiny but
uh going all the way from uh little
dongles uh
like this i'm selling my my phone here
is actually here 3.4 milliwatt
power samsung phone that i have going
all the way up to this
helm one is 13.3 and you can see most of
the ones that
are in a good category are 13 to 14
there isn't anything that's this small
that puts out more power some of these
other ones have more power actually have
batteries in them and what have you
so this is actually quite competent
switching to a very small load 32 ohm
um we get much more power this is
typical we get about 61
milliwatts of power we plug that in and
again we see that it's a
you know same category of of good amount
of
power and so i expect subjective testing
which i'll talk about in a minute
should be pretty good i run a test where
i switch the load from 600 ohm down to
just 12 ohm
and then measure noise and distortion
with 600 and 300 ohm the output just
goes to 2 volts and
can't upward anymore that's that's all
it can do once you go to below 50 ohm
at 51 and below it actually starts
clipping
which is this line and the lower you
make the load eclipse earlier and
earlier and earlier and
earlier because as the resistance goes
up the need for current goes up but if
you have limited current
you just can't go as far as you could
with a higher impedance low
load this table is very useful because
you can look up the impedance of your
headphone
and find the nearest one in here and go
find a clipping point because you don't
want to go past the clipping point so
there's little knees at the at these
points
look down here so what the voltage is
plug it into anything
in here voltage squared divided by
whatever the impedance
is over here and that'll tell you how
much power you're going to get
so there's a newer test as i run it more
and more you'll be able to basically
compute the amount of power you have at
all impedances not just the two that i
was showing you previously
subjective testing is quite important on
these things because
some of these dongles can handle
momentary peaks of power
more than what i'm showing here these
are continuous power both channels
driven whereas in music you may get a
bass
spike that's you know a few milliseconds
so i find that subjectively some of them
sound better than others so
you know you do you have to listen
measurements are good it's a good
baseline but you also listen
uh yeah plug in always my ether cx 25
ohm headphone which i expect
these dongles to not be able to drive
but this little guy had no trouble
driving it and he drove it to medium
level
volume which was good enough enjoyable
usable
very surprising which was good and then
i switched the classic hd
650 sennheiser and it got loud
so uh which which is great i mean you
basically don't need more than that even
in noisy environment you should be able
to listen to it so subjectively
is very good uh objectively is very good
i think there's one product that i've
seen and i recommend this because of
that
there's one product i like better than
this which i reviewed uh
hides or ids however it's pronounced the
s8
and this used to be 129 so more
expensive
it's a bigger dongle but it is
got much better specs in here this is
desktop class uh
sign ad here you can see the distortions
less than 120 b
super product uh similar power but it
was 129
but somebody just pointed out that it's
gone down to eighty dollars on amazon
so if it's eighty dollars and you can
accept this kind of form factor where
you gotta bring your own cable
um this is a preferred device to to this
one but
if you have this or you can get it
cheaper or what have you
this is a great product okay
keep this uh short and sweet uh see you
in the next review
bye-bye